si j'emploie devoir c'est parce que
j'aime le noir le noie c'est
l'instrument majeur de pierre soulages
une obsession dans ses toiles depuis ses
premiers coups de pinceau en 1968 il
tentait d'expliquer son lien à cette
couleur c'est pas tellement un souci de
contrôle qui me qui me fait choisir le
noir c'est un souci d'intensité
d'intensité sur le plan plastique mais
aussi sur l'arrière-plan qui est
finalement là la qualité poétique que
l'on peut tirer de certains contrastes
certaine opposition de certains passages
le noir couleur ou absence de couleur il
est source de mystère soulage
l'accompagnent parfois de touches
colorées mais à ses débuts le plus
souvent ils l'appliquent sur du blanc le
contraste ultime un rapport présence
absence un tableau en noir et blanc
quand on quand on le voit sur un mur il
exclut les couleurs qui l'entourent le
noir dans ce qu'il a de plus profond sur
toute la surface à partir de 1979
soulage pincer outrenoir des toiles
jusqu'à 3 mètres de hauteur très
textures et qu'ils l'appliquent du noir
sur du noir brossé et à layrac les
creuser reste sculpter les reliefs et
les sillons crée ainsi des jeux de
lumière comme l'expliqué l'un des
spécialistes de soulages en 1996 pierre
encrevé quand on se déplace devant la
toile
alternativement le même point et blanc
ou noir
enfin pas forcément blanc ce n'est pas
par la lumière qu'on projette de sud à 7
devant de voir la mer la toile et ont
souvent trait bleu les traces de
soulages interroge l'espace et le temps
le rythme la géométrie la proportion
mais quel message quelle interprétation
lui même en 1998 vingt ans après ses
premiers outre noir
savait pas répondre moi je travaille pas
par désir par plaisir de peindre ou pas
par besoin d'interroger ce que recèle la
peinture que je suis en train de faire
mais c'est toujours ce que je fais qui
m'apprend ce que je cherche la lumière
surgit du noir voilà qui a bâti le
succès de soulages en novembre 2010 9 un
mois avant ses 100 ans
l'artiste a battu son record de ventes
aux enchères son tableau sobrement
baptisé peinture 200 par 162 14 mars
1960 a été adjugée pour un montant de 9
millions six cent mille euros
[Musique]